ross was a fantastic young man the kind
of song that any parent would be
proud of and we were certainly extremely
proud of him and remain
proud of him to this day he
was a devoted family man he
loved his little son charlie who's just
three years old and enjoyed nothing
better than to
play with charlie uh take him swimming
ross was quite
active and sporty and uh he couldn't
uh go to his tennis club or to the gym
uh because of covid uh the last one we
saw him was
christmas we stuck to the raws and that
was the last time we saw him face to
face
we spoke to him virtually every day on
facetime um but ross was
funny he was we had many great laughs
together uh he was a dynamic charismatic
young man who was full of life and
love he loved his family but he was
someone who suffered terribly with
severe depression
and he battled for more than 10 years
to fight that depression and he fought
very hard and tried
most things to try and overcome it and
reach salvation um ross thought that he
had
cracked it to use his praise and he had
to
find and pay for his own counselor and
he particularly
related to his last counsellor and
thought that he turned the corner and
then
uh the depression came back with a
vengeance and
we'll never know for sure but we think
that that's what
um finally pulled the rug from under
russell's feet and he took his life on
the 21st of february
on paper he had so much to live for
a beautiful little boy that we've seen
in your video footage
a fiance a loving family
a great life how much of a factor do you
think
lockdown was in that final decision to
take his life
lockdown and the restrictions associated
with it
didn't kill ross uh it wasn't that that
took his life but it
certainly added to the weight of the
burden that he was carrying
he was due to marry his fiance charlotte
last year
that had to be postponed because
of lockdown her
wedding dress is buried alongside ross
um they were waiting to get married um
when the restrictions were starting to
be
eased and along with all those sort of
restrictions that i mentioned
earlier um you know to do with his sort
of active sporting life and to do with
his family
uh in particular um played quite a sort
of
quite a a hand in what happened
uh to ross but he was also very
frustrated
with the mental health services
we know that there are many
fantastically dedicated people working
out there within the
mental health services but ross was
frustrated
that uh having tried so hard and tried
so many things for ten years that he was
then put on a waiting list for six
months and he died
while he was on that waiting list for
therapy
and my view is and what i'm trying to
to get across now is that you know ross
had what i regard as cancer of the mind
he was in effect terminally ill and if
someone turns up at a doctor's doors or
at a hospital's doors with terminal
cancer
they aren't turned away for six months
and told to
come back after that period um
the mental health provision in this
country i am learning since we lost
ross is woefully inadequate when it
comes to
crisis care and when somebody has taken
the very brave
um step of of contacting
the authorities to say that that is how
they feel
there isn't really the help for them
i've been talking to a lot of people on
social media and
and talking about uh my family's story
and about ross in particular and i've
been inundated with the
messages from people who are in a
situation like
me and my family who
also say that their son their daughter
their father their mother their cousin
whatever
they also died while on a waiting list
and i think
that there has to be some kind of parity
with physical
illness and we have to take these
statistics
very very seriously much more seriously
than we do
at the moment in a few years god willing
covid will be a distant memory
but the suicide rate will still amount
to a pandemic
year in year out every year around the
globe
800 000 people around the world every
year
it's the biggest killer of men under the
age of 45
in this country not cancer not drugs not
road accidents
suicide young men are the biggest
threat to their own futures and their
own lives i was always shocked by that
statistic
even before ross died and the fact that
75
of people who take their own lives are
men is something that we have to look
far more seriously at every suicide
is an equal tragedy be it a man or a
woman
but there is a particular problem with
men and i think it's a cultural societal
problem that we also need to address
um ross wrote a farewell letter to
members of his family am i right in
thinking mike
that he wanted you to do this now to
carry on this work to raise awareness
of mental health issues and the lack of
support that he was able to access in
those
final months he did it was uh quite a
long letter and
uh ross was particularly fond of a
charity called calm
c-a-l-m campaign against living
miserably and he asked
his family to go on campaigning he
addressed each one of us
in turn and he
um said to his son charlie um
he'll be four next month that he thought
he could possibly live on
through charlie without the faults
we of course as parents didn't think
that ross had any faults
um but yeah that was one of the things
and his brother and sister tom and
laura and his mom glennis we've all been
involved in the campaign to try and
raise awareness to try and change the
language around
uh men's health and men's mental health
in particular
to try and get rid of the stigma uh for
example you know we talk about
manning up when men are going through
difficult times
there's a phrase strong silent type for
example
and all of these things i think mean
shut up
don't express it take it on the chin if
you're vulnerable
you're weak and if there's anything that
i would like to get across in russia's
name and in ross's memory
it's that message that to all
all people who are suicidal but young
men in particular
if you are vulnerable and you ask for
help
that is a strength if you cry that is
not
a weakness we men in particular have to
be
more open about this and if we can't get
the language right and we can't get rid
of the stigma
what progress will we ever make and mike
in your experience
in the months following ross's death
how comfortable do you think people are
talking to you
about it um in most cases people have
been exceptionally kind and caring we
have great
um we're very close to our family our
immediate family has always been
very close we did speak to ross a lot
about his
uh problems with with mental health um
and we're supporting each other we're
clinging to each other
we get a great deal of help from the
wider family
and friends and neighbors and people
from all over the world have made
contact with me to
express their condolences and i can't
thank them enough from the bottom of my
heart
and i always just always used to think
as a sky news correspondent
when we had to speak to people who were
bereaved for some reason i always used
to worry about what i could say or do
and came to the conclusion i guess that
there was nothing that i could really
say or do to ease their pain but
since we lost ross i've realized that
actually
um knowing that people are there they've
got your back and they're ready to sort
of catch you if you're
if you fall does make a difference and
what i would say to people is i
understand if you feel
uncomfortable talking about suicide it's
a highly highly sensitive
subject and different people deal with
it in different ways i can only speak to
for myself and my family and i think
mostly we feel that we would rather
speak about ross and
talk about the happy memories that we've
got
because even if we wanted to we'd never
forget him because he was that kind of
person we don't want to forget him he
made the wrong decision and i think he
would ultimately
have found salvation suicide is never
the
answer but that said we'll always be so
proud
to have had him that's our son
mike thank you so much for sharing
ross's story
and talking to us today mike mccarthy
there